This is an interesting drug to discuss because it's also a good drug which gives you some examples how it was successfully developed.
And I think even if you are not in GVHD field, I think you might be coming across as a part of your patient treatment or as a part of other interests.
Because this drug is being combined with lymphoma, with CAR-T, is being combined with the breast cancer treatment, and is becoming combined in AML treatment.
So let me talk to you a little bit about what others it had and why it was developed in the chronic GVHD.
Just as a disclaimer, I usually talk how there is very little chronic GVHD.
So here I want to give you a little bit more why it is still important to think about some late and old complications.
The common denominator is there is around 30% chronic GVHD in all patients.
It's maybe a little bit less, but it's a real number.
We had very few drugs in the past, in the last few years, that have been exploding.
We have four approved FDA drugs.
And what I'm specifically proud of, three of these drugs came from a mouse model.
So this was a real bench to the translation of an entire GVHD group.
It is a devastating complication of the transplant, specifically in the patients who are in remission.
And we have seen, probably saying, there is less complication of this.
But as I'll try to argue with you, it's important still to think about it.
Because as we are getting into these multimodal treatments,
and where there's the treatment of hematological malignancy patients remains on the continuum,
meaning patients get treated, get transplanted, get another drug, come back,
this will be still becoming an issue.
And it's important to pay attention because it's multisystemic disease.
So we argue in the recent blood paper here on the left,
where we look with PTCI, we have decreased incidence of chronic GVHD in the other drugs.
But on the right, we try to give where is the field going on in the next 10 years,
if we estimate.
So what you can see on the right, and these are relatively small to see,
that number of the patient, just by default because we are increasing the number of the transplant every year,
despite all these great drug development, there is still increasing number of the patient,
it's going to be to become a reality.
And not only that, currently there is around 25,000 patients sitting in US with this complication.
And in less than years, there's going to be additional 50.
Each of these patients is very, very small.
It's very complex.
It's around 300K just to manage these patients and very few stop immunosuppression.
So it's important to still stay on top of these medications.
As I mentioned, there are four different drugs.
And what's interesting with axotelimab, it works very differently because GVHD is the T cell mediated disease,
but axotelimab rather works on efferent arm, meaning on the monocytes, prevents this tissue injury of the monocytes.
So it's a very different drug.
It's biological.
It's its antibody.
So how does it compare with other drugs?
As I mentioned, it is a recently approved drug for the second line, and it's usually used as a biological agent.
There had been recent trial which confirmed efficacy of this drug.
And what he can also learn there that it is biologically different.
GVHD is a three-stage concept for her first conditioning injury, then T cell injury, and the last part is the really,
what's happening in the tissue.
So this is really affecting the last part, which can put completely in the tissues.
And we have now a lot of different biomarkers how we can assess what is happening in these organs.
So the P-model trial had been recently published 2024 in New England Journal of Medicine.
So this is now FDA-approved drug.
So what we have learned there that response to this drug is pretty good, even if there are multiple previous therapies, around 70% of them are positive.
previous therapies, around 70% of the patients can respond, but very few patients have sustained
response. GVHD, as mentioned, is really syndrome rather than disease, multiple different
manifestations. So drug walks across the spectrum, probably not as good as most devastating
complication to chronic GVHD, which is the lung GVHD, but in combination with steroids, it had
pretty good and decent activity in the patient who had already failed other medications, which are
other two FDA-approved medications. So is this really going on beyond just the clinical trial?
And for this kind of situation, I like always to believe in the extended access program and as well
see what are our European colleagues seeing, because they cannot get this drug as quickly and as rapidly
as we can in U.S. So I'll highlight two of the developments just to increase the strength, why this is a
reasonable approach. So there was a recent blood paper which really looked long-term follow-up of
these patients, and the response of these patients remained the same in high 70% range. But as it can
be seen here on a third one, that only 15% of the patients remain on the drug. Are they failed or most
likely chronic GVHD? And I think that's a really good question. I think that's a really good question.
chronic GVHD continues. So this is not panacea, but it has a very good efficacy for the patients.
And it can have even less side effects the longer you give this drug because this is
a biological agent. So it is not as much as a T cell depleting agent. So infections are
not as much an issue as what you have seen with other chronic GVHD treatments. What was
also very interesting with this drug is that there was no difference in the dose. Originally
it was tried 0.3 and one milligram. And what we always learn multiple times in biologicals
that more does not mean better. So current standard dose is 0.3 milligrams given every
four weeks. This had been also, as I mentioned, looked if the extended access program what
had initially incited or what did Europeans repeated. And I think that pretty much the
results are the same.
Response rates around 70 percent, decreasing incidence of complications as you continue
with this drug. There is efficacy, but what is the field already doing is that we are
now not treating patients with one. We are sometimes treating patients with two or three
different drugs for those who are not responding. Basically saying we have multiple drugs in
the chronic GVHD field, which is very exciting for us because we never had agents to try
to play and design these innovative clinical trials.
But this is what the field is doing. But what is also happening, very interesting and what
I really like that initial developers are realizing this drug, if it needs to be given
in the clinic and needs to be given on the monthly clinic, we are all loaded in our clinics.
And what's also we don't want this patient to come in every month because they might
be sitting 600 kilometers from our center. There is this increasing use of this medication
through the outside vendors where they can get this medication at home through the monitoring
program. So there is now increasing data and this is now even being approved by CMS that
you can administer this drug on the shorter follow up through the outpatient clinic. And
there is more and more data showing that this drug can be even decreased in the dose. So
I am very attuned for you who are interested in the drug to tap into this program because
it allows you easier management of these patients. And even as a transplanter, as we are trying
to tap more into this home-based infusion program, which can decrease the volumes in
our clinic and also give the better quality of the life for the patient. And this is the
very new interesting thing, what I'm seeing with the availability of this drug, because
this is not T-cell depleted, this is rather biologicals.
So for all of you who are interested and want to combine these drugs with other ones, because
your patients might not be responding, there are now different trials trying to combine
this with other biological agents.
There are different biological agents, specifically JAK inhibitors in the clinic. And as I mentioned,
there will be more and more of these patients specifically as they start to relapse and
we give non-relapse treating agents, which might be provoking chronic GVHD. Some of you
might have experience when you put a patient on a FLT3 inhibitors, you can hear this rebound
GVHD, some of them develop the chronic GVHD.
So I think it's important to stay tuned and I think there is more combination. And I think
in GVHD field, they are really trying to decrease more from T-cell depleting agents and getting
more into these biologicals. And I think we have interesting drugs to play with it. Thank
you very much.